[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in this video we're going
to be discussing pockets and the pockets
of many of our favorite characters if
you didn't know already a pocket is
essentially the manifestation of your
deepest darkest fears it is an immortal
shape-shifting non-being that transforms
itself into whatever you fear most no
one knows what a boggart looks like by
itself because it will transform as soon
as you encounter it when pockets aren't
scaring people they can usually be found
rustling around and confined spaces or
lurking around dark corners similar to
poltergeists which have an affinity for
mischief Fink peeves and Dementors which
thrive on darkness and depression
pockets are paired with fear one of the
most interesting things about pockets is
that when they transform into something
they can replicate its abilities ie when
a pocket transformed into a Dementor
it's able to do all of the horrible
things that their mentor can it's worth
mentioning however that the pockets
abilities will be very suppressed
compared to the original creature or
being here are some other interesting
facts about pockets if you encounter a
boggart
with someone else it made him to
transform itself into a combination of
both of their fears which will usually
end up just being silly if you have
multiple fears each is bad as the last a
boggart will cycle through those fears
and show you all of them in sequence the
best offense against the Boggart
is the Boggart banishing spell also
known as ridiculous in order to
successfully cast the spell on a pocket
you can't show it in fear as the spells
intent is to make the Boggart appear
well ridiculous light-hearted and fun
rather than scary before we dive into
this list of each character's Bahgat I
thought that it would be worth
mentioning that a large majority of the
characters of the Harry Potter have
Voldemort listed as their Bhagat this is
for obvious reasons and it almost seems
like a given that he'd be a boggart to
many as Voldemort is the most feared
Dark Wizard of all time I also just
wanted to mention that not all of these
pockets are actually confirmed and some
of them I will be theorizing based on
their character
I will specify if they're listed pocket
has been confirmed or not without
further ado let's get into the list
first we'll look at the ones that are
mentioned in cannon number one Harry
Potter
Dementors Harry's Bhagat is a Dementor
the kiss Dementors make you relive your
most fearful memories something that
Harry has a lot of number two Ron
Weasley Aragog Ron suffers from
arachnophobia system surprise that Ron's
boggart is a giant arachnid number three
Hermione Granger Hermione's boggart is
McGonagall giving her a failing grade on
her exam this should come as no surprise
as she's very studious number four
Parvati Patil a mummy number five Albus
Dumbledore the corpse of his sister
Ariana and potentially being blamed for
her death number six Tom Marvolo riddle
his own corpse
aside from power Voldemort's big thing
is achieving immortality so it's no
surprise that his Bhagat is his own
death number seven Remus Lupin a full
moon and transforming into his werewolf
form number eight Neville Longbottom
Severus Snape idiot boor number nine
Dean Thomas a disembodied severed hand
walking on its own number ten Seamus
Finnigan a banshee with floor-length
black hair and a skeletal green face
number eleven Molly Weasley a rotation
of corpses belonging to the people that
she loves and that concludes the canon
confirmed boggarts
now we'll get into the theorize pockets
I should mention that some of these
characters have Voldemort as they're
listed Bhagat but that isn't canon and
I'm not content with that generic answer
so I've taken the liberty of introducing
some alternatives number 12
Severus Snape most likely Lily Potter's
corpse or possibly Voldemort number 13
Draco Malfoy the people that he loves
dying because of his own actions the
product of his pride of bravado getting
in the way of how he truly feels number
Bellatrix
or dying or possibly Dumbledore number
15 serious black hairy dying or possibly
Bellatrix number 16 Ginny Weasley
similar to her mother a cycle of the
corpses of all of those that she loves
number 17 Arthur Weasley
Molly Weasley's corpse Cornelius fudge
or Lucius Malfoy number 18 Fred Weasley
George Weasley's corpse number 19 George
Weasley Fred Weasley's corpse number 20
James Potter Harry and/or Lily's corpse
number 21
Lily Potter Harry and/or James's corpse
number 22 Luna Lovegood a world without
magic and magical creatures her dead
mother or maybe her by herself with no
friends number 23 Dolores Umbridge lack
of order Voldemort or centaurs number 24
Barty Crouch jr. a disappointed
Voldemort or possibly his father number
25 Barty Crouch senior Lord Voldemort
number 26 Peter Pettigrew definitely
Lord Voldemort number 27 Fenrir Greyback
Greyback is definitely a bit of a savage
so my best guess is that his pocket
would be similar to Lord Voldemort his
own corpse
number 28 Lucius Malfoy Voldemort number
29 Narcissa Malfoy the corpses of her
family number 30 in fedora lupins corpse
number 31 Antonin dalla HOF Voldemort's
corpse number 32
Cornelius fudge definitely Voldemort
Cornelius feared Voldemort so much that
he was blindly ignorant to his return
number 33 Viktor Krum Voldemort number
34 Minerva McGonagall her husband
Elphinstone burkhardt's corpse
number 35 Pomona sprouts the Hogwarts
green houses set on fire number 36
Cedric Diggory Voldemort number 37
Gilderoy Lockhart Cornish Pixies number
38 Quirrell Voldemort number 39 Hagrid a
cycle of all of his pet Stein Fang
fluffy Norbert's Aragog Buckbeak etc
number 40 filius Flitwick the
disbandment of the frog choir number 41
poppy Pomfrey a cycle of patience that
she was unable to help number 42 Alastor
mad-eye moody it's speculated that moody
could actually see the authentic
appearance of a bhagat most likely via
his magical eye number 43 Rufus
Scrimgeour the fall of the ministry or
possibly Lord Voldemort number 44
Dobby Harry Potter's corpse number 45
Nagini either Voldemort or Creedence as
corpse number 46 Igor Karkaroff
returning to Azkaban prison number 47
Filch mrs. norris dying number 48
Moaning Myrtle the basilisk number 49
Slughorn a young Tom Riddle number 50
Trelawney failing to exercise divination
when requested and that's it for this
video I'm sure I've missed a few
characters but this video really could
go on and on so I thought that this
could be a good starting point if you
want more I can make more I purposely
didn't include any of the characters
from fantastic beasts as I would rather
make a separate video on what did you
guys think of my character boggart
theories who would you have changed
what would your pocket be let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time you're a wizard Harry